♪ (upbeat music) ♪
With Flutter, it can be easy
to create a great-looking screen
full of awesome widgets.
But how hard is it to create
a bunch of screens
and let your user
swipe between them?
If you use the PageView widget,
turns out it's not that hard at all.
The first thing you need
is a PageController,
which manages swipe detection
and provides the animation.
Use the initialPage property
to set which page it starts on.
Then create your pages
using the PageView widget,
and give it the controller
and the pages to show.
What to scroll your pages vertically?
Just set the scrollDirection to vertical.
And that's it.
By using PageView and PageController,
your users can swipe through the screens
to their heart's content.
For more info on PageView
and all the other Flutter widgets
Head to flutter.io
♪ (upbeat music) ♪